do you have a chance at Olaf Schultz has
spoken by phone with Russian President
Vladimir Putin and called for a
ceasefire in Ukraine as soon as possible
President Putin is said to have
responded by blaming Ukraine for
stalling negotiations but at a meeting
of G7 foreign ministers in Germany
Ukraine accused Russia of preferring
Wars to talks attending the summit as a
guest Ukrainian foreign minister dimitro
kulaba are called on the gathered
representatives of some of the world's
largest industrialized economies to step
up arms supplies to his country and put
more pressure on Russia this is EU
Foreign Affairs Chief Joseph Burrell
used the meeting to announce another
half a billion euros in military aid to
Ukraine G7 countries have promised to
support Ukraine until victory night and
let's go through these events with DW
political correspondent Benjamin Alvarez
Gruber here in Berlin and our chief
International correspondent Richard
Walker is at the G7 meeting in weissen
house in Northern Germany welcome both
and let's start with you uh Benjamin
what else did President Putin and
Chancellor Schultz discuss today
phone call Germany said that it took 75
minutes where Chancellor Olaf Schultz
urged the Russian president to end the
war as soon as possible Germany said
that they addressed specifically the
situation in Mario poll and something
that Chancellor Schultz tweeted
afterwards he said that the claim that
Nazis rule in Ukraine is full something
that President Putin in Russia is of
course seeing as a pretext for its
invasion in Ukraine
uh Richard Walker a lot of people are
going to be looking at this and
wondering well Chancellor Schultz might
as well have saved his breath why would
President Putin change his mind as a
result of a phone call is there any
significance to this call
well of course it is a pretty uh long
history in recent months of trying to
communicate with Vladimir Putin also in
the weeks leading up to the war he was
one of the leaders who trached through
Moscow sat at that very long table in
Moscow and tried to communicate with
Putin try to dissuade him from from
beginning this war obviously the war has
now been underway for a long time this
is the first communication that they've
had in several weeks so it's quite
striking that this phone phone call has
taken place now and on such a scale at
75 minutes I think you know one of the
things to stress about this kind of
phone call is it's partly about Olaf
Schultz getting his message across to
Vladimir Putin
um trying to display the unity that the
West has been so Keen to show with other
partners within the west but also for
the Germans and for other people who've
tried to keep up communication with
Putin it's also about the communication
the other way they want to try to
understand where he is in his head and
it at this place in this context in this
conflict
um how close he might be uh to uh to
some kind of serious attempt at
negotiations so it's a two-way
communication it's not just about
getting messages across to Vladimir
Putin is also about trying to understand
Vladimir Putin his position at this
stage in the conflict and how close uh
things could be to trying to find a
negotiated into it Benjamin Alvarez
group I mean the first call in six weeks
between the two leaders why pick up the
phone now
if we look at the current context
Ukraine is of course the topic of
Ukraine the situation of the war is
taking center stage at the G7 foreign
ministers meeting here in Germany the
foreign minister kuleba met with a
German politicians both from the
government and also from the opposition
but Germany is taking a more active role
there has been a lot of pressure not
only from the opposition but also by
government parties for scholts to be
quicker when it comes to deployment of
heavy weapons and Germany is not just
will send these heavy weapons but has
also recently started training Ukrainian
soldiers here in Germany so that's of
course taking a more active role and
what they saying what Germany is saying
is that German Chancellor Olaf Schultz
spoke to the Ukrainian president only a
few days ago so he's trying to maintain
the contact but of course Schultz and
Putin there was a long silence for
several weeks the last phone call was at
the end of March before we got those
cerebral's pictures out of the city of
which are close to the Ukrainian Capital
so now he's trying once again to
communicate it to both sides so Richard
let's talk about these stalled peace
talks because once again we have each
side blaming the other for a lack of
progress
yeah that's right Phil and dimitro
culeba the the Ukrainian foreign
minister is here in Northern Germany at
this blustery setting for for these
talks of of G7 foreign ministers
um he was asked about this uh just
earlier when he came out to give a
statement
um about what is the status of potential
negotiations not just on the overall
potential route to an end to this
conflict but also on specific issues
such as trying to get Ukrainian grain
supplies back onto the Seas uh Pastor
Russian blockade and he said that in
both cases that the Russians were not
responding favorably to Ukraine's
suggestions for for holding talks and
saying that essentially Russia prefers
War to talks
um now of course both sides will be
blaming each other for um you know a
lack of progress here but of course the
benefit of the doubt of the
International Community is going to be
with the ukrainians after all it was the
Russians who invaded Ukraine it's then
it's pretty rich some might say for the
Russians then to invade and then to say
to the ukrainians why aren't you talking
to us
I Know Chief International editor
Richard Walker thank you for that DW
political correspondent Benjamin Alvarez
Gruber thank you
and we'll get an update on the situation
on the ground in Ukraine from DW
reporter Alex Forest Whiting
Ukrainian forces are continuing their
counter-offensive against Russian troops
in the northeast of the country most
notably in and around kharkiv now
kharkiv is Ukraine's second largest city
and has been a major Russian Target
since the start of moscow's invasion at
the end of February Russian troops have
had some success in capturing areas
around the city particularly to the
north but Ukrainian forces are
continuing to push them back and they
claim to have recaptured several
villages to the northeast of khakive
they're also said to be within just a
few kilometers of the Russian border
Ukraine's pushback is also helping to
alleviate Russian Artillery pressure on
the city of kharkiv which is protecting
civilians from Russian Ground Force
shelling but there are still Russian
rocket strikes on the city with at least
two civilians killed on Thursday there
military experts though are beginning to
wonder if Ukraine's counter-offensive
around kharkiv is actually looking
similar to that around the capital Kiev
which Russian troops were driven out of
at the end of March now Russia has
already taken the city of itsium but
appears to be struggling to advance
south from there and that's partly
because Ukrainian forces have been
trying to cut off Russian supply lines
north of the city Moscow though is still
very much focusing its power on the
donbass region which includes the cities
of luhansk and Don yesque now remember
that prior to moscow's February Invasion
russian-backed separatists held a
significant amount of territory there
and Russian forces have been trying to
encircle Ukrainian troops in the region
and there has been intense fighting
there this week now although moscow's
Advance has been slow even Ukraine has
acknowledged that Russia has achieved a
partial success there as they have
advanced towards cities like severo Don
yensk now military experts believe
Russia will launch a ground offensive on
or around that City in the coming days
although they stress it is not at all
certain if Russia will succeed but
Ukrainian forces are still putting up a
very strong fight in the region and
British intelligence reported on Friday
that Ukraine stopped Russian troops
trying to cross a river west of severo
Don yensk and Ukrainian forces are said
to have destroyed a bridge there and
also parts of a Russian armored column
let's see if we can get an insight into
the thinking of the Russian president
with mikhaila cassiniov who was Russian
Prime Minister under President to Putin
between 2000 and 2004 a former Putin
Ally he became a leading political
opponent and now lives in Exile he joins
us from an undisclosed location in
Europe welcome to DW
um can we start with where you stand on
Ukraine's on Russia's war in Ukraine
yeah that's absolutely clear it's
absolutely religious my position was
absolutely clear from from the beginning
just Invasion to to George and
annexation of Crimea that's absolutely
clear I was one of the organizers of
those protests in their marches in
Moscow against against Roy McCray and of
course today's war is absolutely brutal
undertaken by Mr Putin and couldn't keep
just every normal Russian just
indifferent to this we absolutely
condemned this criminal activity of Mr
Buddhist regime it's interesting you
make the link back to George you said
Georgia through through Crimea and of
course now to to Ukraine do you see this
as being do you see the war Russia's war
in Ukraine as being part of a longer
term strategy that uh Vladimir Putin has
been pursuing
uh I wouldn't say just long-term
strategy of Putin but it is long-term
just patience of of the western world
and Germany in particular and I think
just I can remind you that in 2008 after
just blockage of the providing so-called
just the entry map or just role plant
for Ukraine and Georgia to enter NATO it
was Bucharest Summit of NATO in in April
2014. right after that Mr puyon arranged
the provocation in Georgia in Bay
Georgia but the Western walls and
reacted very very calmly on there just
two three months after that just
business as usual that was the
relationship including Germany and that
time and relaxation of Crimea of course
that was just a major step of Germany
first of all I remember merkeland that
she first was who employs sanctions
against Putin regime as a result of
annexation of Crimea and the war and
dunbars but it was not so cash Mr Putin
right thought he could overcome and
that's happened now and so just just to
be clear you believe that we are here
now with Russia invading
um a Ukraine because the West did not
act resolutely enough right at the start
of this process perhaps even going back
as far as Georgia
the case Mr Putin as a result of those
reactions Western reaction Mr Putin
taken this took this as I would say
permitted behavior and that's why he
believed that violation of international
law that's allowed him to do this by
Western World all right let's let's see
if we can pick your brain as it were
given your your knowledge of the man
let's let's turn to his his rare public
appearance at the May 9th uh Victory Day
Parade there was no declaration of war
and no National mobilization as had been
expected why do you think those
announcements weren't made
I didn't expect there would be
announcement of war and mobilization
because of the simple reason if Putin
would have taken we would do this would
done this it would be demonstration of
his weakness that special operation
failed and just he called for the whole
Russian Russian World to help him to get
out of this situation and that's why it
couldn't happen and it didn't but the
reaction Mr Putin and his speech was
absolutely weak and and he is I would
say Behavior was a little bit nervous
and he I would say I would say just
already started to realize that he
losing this war especially after all
those demonstrations of the European
Union Great Britain and United States
just over those decisions of delivery of
military equipment that is already just
creating some kind of I've not yet but
some kind of Advantage decisive
advantage of Ukraine in the near future
I believe all right and the fact that
Russia is is doing so badly in this war
perhaps not as well as would have been
expected what do you make of the theory
that one of the reasons it's Prosecuting
this war so badly is that President
Putin isn't getting a full picture
because he's journals and his inner
circle are scared to give him bad news
yeah I'm sure he was misled he believed
that his army in a great shape and he
would undertake these efforts this
operation as he called the Williams
three five days one week maximum and
we'll get just the maximum he wanted to
Jerusalem change he announced even you
can you can remember he called for the
Ukrainian militaries just to change the
regime by their hands and that was his
he his his goal and occupy just south
and Eastern Eastern Ukraine but now he
failed to achieve this and that's why
just I'm saying right now we're coming
to another stage this competition of
rivalry of economic potentials military
potentials and that's why it's so
important that the United States made a
decision to provide land lease program
it means just to create a potential
effort of economic potential for Ukraine
and that will be just long-standing of
War for a few months I guess foreign
take advantage of your knowledge of the
man having worked closely with Vladimir
Putin in the early in the early years of
his presidency and indeed before that
how would you say he has changed
yeah I worked with him 20 years ago it
was completely different person it was
completely different situation at that
time we had Parliament independent
Parliament we have Independent Media we
had Judiciary today is completely
different walk Mr Putin destroyed all
features of democratic State and now
just we have absolute authoritarian
regime and you readily moving to the
Planetarium one that's completely
different person completely different
situation right now
good talking to you thank you so much
for your insights uh mikhaila cassinioff
a former Russian Prime Minister now
political Exile and Putin opponent thank
you
thank you
Ukraine and its allies are fighting
Russia on another front ever since the
invasion there have been widespread
fears of cyber attacks experts are
surprised that Russia hasn't taken down
Ukraine's power grid or other critical
infrastructure but Ukrainian hackers
have mounted their own successful
counter cyber attacks
an unlikely Soldier Boston ivasco is a
software developer and now part of
Ukraine's I.T Army striking Russian
Targets in cyberspace he helps hack
official websites one of thousands of
ukrainians who aim to show Russians what
is really happening in Ukraine
unfiltered by state censorship
we try to disrupt the propaganda machine
and
infiltrate
different systems of
Russian government Russian structures
this is a message to Vladimir Putin from
Anonymous Ukraine cyber Warriors have
been joined by the international hacking
Collective Anonymous it says it is not
against Russia's people or even its
soldiers but against President Putin and
his apparatus and it wants to keep
Russia's own cyber experts busy so they
can't attack Ukraine or the West
Russia has a long history of alleged
cyber attacks on Ukraine and other
countries it's believed to have hacked
into Ukraine's presidential elections
and taken out parts of its power grid as
well as trying to destroy internet
connectivity
but Russia has always maintained its
innocence claiming that criminal groups
not the government were responsible
now with people like Bogdan and
Ukraine's hacker Army against it Russia
finds itself on the receiving end of
these attacks with more likely to follow
our chief technology correspondent is
yanosh delka yeah I remember sitting
here in the very first days of the war
reporting on this Invasion unfolding the
uh an information War breaking out at
the very same time and also this
Prospect of a massive cyber event what
happened to that it's true Ben I mean in
the early days of the war like many
experts warned that there would be a
massive attack there could be a massive
attack on Ukraine's digital
infrastructure that could also have
spillover effects all around the world
no you know this kind of cyber
apocalypse has not materialized but what
we have seen is something else that's
unprecedented and that's the rise the
emergence of a new form of cyber
guerrilla warfare if you will we have
hacktivists around the world hackers
around the world who have become
involved and what's new is also that the
Ukrainian government itself encourages
people to do so tell me a bit more about
these so-called gorillas who who are
they and and why did they even get
involved in this yeah and that's what we
wanted to find out so we a track down
some of them talk to some of them and
there's no easy answer so I mean they
have different motives they use
different cyber weapons they have
different kind of expertise in hacking
but um you know when it comes to the
sort of pro Ukrainian side our reporting
suggest that there are three groups
there are cyber Security Experts often
in Ukraine then there are hactivists
around the world Anonymous the
collective maybe most prominently and um
then there are volunteers who have
little or no experience in hacking I
talk for example to a man in Denmark you
know this I.T guy in his mid-40s who
said like he's never even broken the law
before this or you know or done anything
with hacking but now he spent several
hours every day attacking Russian
websites and trying to bring them down
and you know these kind of
attacks that they're running they're not
sophisticated cyber operations they're
more like online vandalism but they do
have an impact as well tell us more
about the other actors involved I mean
of course there are criminals in there
like ransomware groups um that usually
use hacking to make money
um and then of course there are State
actors there are intelligent services
and their partners and the truth there
is that their work mostly remains in the
dark
so um you know it's just part of part of
their work it's hacktivists like to talk
about what they achieve if they you know
bring down a site or something secret
Services don't do that because it could
compromise their activities
um but
many experts are convinced that there is
quite a bit happening in the dark so the
Cyber operations we're seeing might only
be the tip of the iceberg just one more
thing um we we've talked a lot about and
compared a lot the the Russian forces to
the Ukrainian forces what about in the
online War uh how well-equipped would
you say the ukrainians are well that's
very difficult to say because the
ukrainians has become sort of like the
pro Ukrainian side is spread all around
the world now and there are various
different sort of like levels of
expertise what we know is that the
Ukrainian government and the Ukrainian
side has support by International tech
companies and they also have the support
by other countries and that of course
helps them and you know another thing
that we have to keep in mind Ukraine has
a lot of experience with thwarting cyber
attacks
thank you very much for coming in today
very exciting interesting stuff thank
you